[Musique]
et on direct ce soir jean-pierre ternes
amian radiologue président de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé
des médecins libéraux en 2 vergne
rhône-alpes et philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial college de londres et à
l'université lille ii bonsoir messieurs
merci de répondre à nos questions si de
nouvelles mesures ne sont pas mises en
place rapidement le coc u19 pourrait
être plus présent cet été que l'été
dernier c'est ce qu'estime aujourd'hui
le conseil scientifique
jean-pierre ternes amis ans si les
médecins disent souvent je n'ai pas à
dire s'il faut confiné ou pas c'est une
décision politique
là on peut quand même dire que le corps
médical dans son ensemble depuis
quelques temps fait de la politique en
disant il faut confiné non c'est pas que
le corps médical fait on veut dire de la
politique c'est qu'on a des patients à
prendre en charge et qu'actuellement on
sait plus faire parce que on a quasiment
plus de capacité de mutation de nos
patients auraient à la seule zone qui
reste dans notre région c'est l'eau
l'ouest on va dire clermont ferrand et
qu'on a plus on a un taux d'occupation
en ré à tous les leaders et à son plat
faut pas oublier qu'on est dans une
seule case où on a les vies qui sont
occupées par la chirurgie de rattrapage
des épisodes précédents et maintenant ça
devient majoritairement du colis donc la
seule marge de manoeuvre qu'on a c'est
ce qu'on appelle les us et les unités de
soins continus qui sont des réanimations
de niveau un peu inférieur plutôt dans
les hôpitaux privés et cela soit en des
programmes la totalité de la chirurgie
est bien évidemment c'est un impact pour
la population et à son land encore un
tout petit peu de marge de manoeuvre
dans tous les cas cette marge de
manoeuvre
on en a qu on en a pas en pratique il
faudra dire au monde ce soir sont en
santé publique france 1 5000 patients
soit un critique c'est l'une des idées
info de la soirée
pierre jeantet reniant je donne la
parole maintenant à philippe froguel la
une de libération ce matin c'était il
attend quoi avec une photo des manuels
macron il attend quoi selon vous contre
il est malade à l'hôpital ligne rouge
absolue selon le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire a ce matin
moi j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement a pas envie de prendre de
décisions contraignantes
sinon on l'aurait il aurait déjà fait je
suis pas sûr qu'il a qui ne croit nous
les médecins quand on dit que ça va
s'aggraver il attend godot c'est à dire
que les mains et mesure qu il n'a pas
pris depuis un mois soit soit vraiment
efficace simplement s'agit pas de
modélisation on est un taux de
reproduction du virus qui est de 115% en
france donc on aura quinze pour cent de
plus de patients à dents dans une
semaine et on aura donc 15 % de
personnes en plus qui risquent de se
retrouver en réanimation et ça c'est pas
des modélisations sais c'est obligatoire
ensuite quand on se pose des questions
sur un plus long terme et via un plus
long terme j'en sais rien ça va dépendre
de la rapidité la vaccination qui quand
même pas très très rapide en france pour
l'instant sans efficacité l'arrivée de
nouveaux variants ce que feront les
français qui ont été quand même très
très démobilisés parlent parlent le
breton la république qui à force de dire
c'est pas la peine de confiner on l'a vu
le week-end dernier à paris personne
était confiné ça c'est évident donc on a
de quoi être un petit peu pessimiste et
quant à ce que frag président ou pas à
prédire
je suis pas sûr ça change grand chose
aujourd'hui puisque il me paraît pas
très prêt à faire ce qu'on a fait dans
d'autres pays c'est à dire des
confinement strict et eux ont baissé le
r et quant à la vaccination et quand
elle continuera à la vitesse actuelle et
c'est à dire que ça sera se passera l'an
parce que ce qu'on voit dans les
animations aujourd'hui c'est plus des
gens de 80 ans c'est déjà 50 président
dans et souvent des gens comme des
enfants en collège au lycée et ceux là
vont continuer ce qu'ils seront pas
vaccinés avant le mois de mai juin aux
mille
vous avez parlé du r1 je reprends pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas le rc le le
taux de reproduction du virus
on a évoqué à emmanuel macron ne sais
pas s'il va parler ou pas demain ou plus
tard
messieurs en tous les cas on est le 30
mars aujourd'hui il ya quatre semaines
début mars
regardez ce qu'ils emmanuel macron et
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement disait pendant quatre à six
semaines on va devoir encore passer par
des phases de gros temps par des phases
de remous par des phases difficiles
ce qui est certain c'est que la
vaccination c'est un progrès majeur dans
la lutte contre cette épidémie on
commence à observer les tout premiers
signes de l'impact de la vaccination sur
certains publics particulièrement
vulnérable sur le nombre de foyers de
contamination dans les ehpad qui
diminuent sur le taux d'incidence sur
les personnes très âgées les plus de 80
ans qui semble commencer à diminuer
c'est très préliminaire mais c'est un
signe voilà donc gabriel atteint qui
disait il faut attendre quatre à six
semaines
il faut encore tenir il parlait un le
lendemain puisque c'était le 1er mars 5
emmanuel macron avait dit il faut
obtenir encore quatre à six semaines
bon là ça fait quatre semaines donc faut
attendre encore attendre deux semaines
pour avoir les fameuses six semaines
mais mes bons force est de constater que
le calendrier de sortie de crise en tous
les cas il
ils changent sans cesse vous comprenez
que les français ont besoin de voir le
bout du tunnel
pierre interne amiens non je pense que
là si vous voulez il y avait une
déclaration qui était on va dire
beaucoup trop précoce parce que si on
avait pris des mesures de confinement
strict ya quatre ou six semaines
il ya quatre semaines on serait
absolument pas dans le désastre
sanitaire qu'on va vivre pendant les
quinze jours trois semaines
il faut quand même se rendent compte que
sur ma région le taux d'incidence
demande pratiquement entre 10 30 points
tous les jours on est actuellement très
bien entendu 800 cas pour 100000
habitants par exemple dans le val d'oise
oui mais bon sur notre région qui a été
très impacté si vous voulez sur la
première vague la deuxième vague aussi
on était légèrement en retrait mais le
problème si vous voulez c'est
qu'actuellement on est d'accord que sur
une toute petite frange de la population
on a un effet un impact on commence à
avoir un impact sur la vaccination mais
je rejoins tout à fait ce que dit mon
confrère cirque l'impact de la
vaccination on va la voir la fin de
l'été parce que c'est plus un taux de
couverture à 70% qu'il faudra
probablement ses taux de couverture à
95%
on a actuellement si vous voulez en
arriver cette semaine à millions de
vaccins
astrazeneca la semaine prochaine ses 300
milles et la semaine d'après ces trois
cent mille donc quelque part si vous
voulez on apprenait on est dans
l'incapacité de protéger la population
et comment on n'a pas pris des mesures
courageuses il ya à peu près trois
semaines au moment où on commençait à
voir la remontée et on était nombreux a
quand même fait remarquer l'impérieuse
nécessité déjà de faire respecter le
confinement actuel d'employés donc quand
on vous écoute ça veut dire qu emmanuel
macron aurait dû donc confiné fin
janvier début février quand il avait
pris donc ce pari politique de ne pas le
faire la semaine dernière il avait le
conseil européen à l'issue duquel il
s'est exprimé jeudi soir il a estimé
qu'il avait bien fait de ne par confiner
philippe froguel quand vous entendez le
président parlait ainsi le bout du
tunnel c'est con selon vous on sait qu'à
l'un de vos confrères djillali annane le
chef du service de réanimation de
l'hôpital raymond poincaré à garches et
a10 pas dix ans avant avant de revenir à
la normale
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que en
a tant qu'on n'aura pas 80 85 % au moins
des gens ils sont utilisés que ce soit
parce qu'ils ont faim les maladies ou
parce qu'ils ont été vaccinées on aura
beaucoup beaucoup de monde très malade
et et des gens dans les hôpitaux passe
parce que ça touche de plus en plus des
personnes relativement jeunes et c'est
ça notre problème aujourd'hui a dit
qu'on va avoir
pendant le printemps pendant tout le
printemps quoi qu'on fasse aujourd'hui
c'est bien ça qui est dramatique c'est
que la seule chose qu'on a à faire pour
diminuer ces faire ce que le président
macron ne veut pas et à décourager à peu
près là toute la population de le faire
c'est à dire un confinement très fort
comme on en a on a eu en angleterre
malgré la vaccination ou comme en israël
comme certains autres pays
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le choix c'est
pas c'est pas pareil et et de coeur mais
leur activation sera très lent ne
touchent pas aujourd'hui les des cibles
du virus principal puisque dans les
ehpad ils ont été vaccinés les épater un
million de personnes et et pour le reste
si on ne protège pas les jambes par des
mesures de confinement par la fermeture
des écoles et autres
eh bien on sait ce qui va se passer dans
les trois mois qui viennent ensuite j'en
sais rien le pic de la deuxième vague
est franchie on le redit le chiffre ce
soir
5000 patients en soins critiques donc le
monde médical est pessimiste vous êtes
pessimiste vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
philippe froguel regarder également la
sortie tout à l'heure de l'un de vos
confrères jean-françois timsit le chef
de réanimation de l'hôpital bichat à
paris
je peux le dire sans être grand clerc
dont deux semaines on aura six cents
morts par jour ce sont les personnes qui
se contaminent aujourd'hui que l'on
verra en réanimation dans quinze jours
on est déjà dans la nasse jean-françois
timsit qui a déploré également récemment
ya un an
l'odyssey les médecins le corps médical
et soignant avec maintenant les médecins
et tout ce monde tout ce personnel
soignant est bien est considéré comme le
père fouettard 600 morts par jour dans
deux semaines
il faut quoi alors faut fermer les
écoles pour sauver l'hôpital c'est ça
mais si on ferme les écoles les parents
gardent leurs enfants ils vont pas
travailler
donc du coup l'économie chute la santé
moral des français s'effondre également
c'est cornélien comme situation
c'est je dirais la situation est
d'autant plus cornélienne que s'ils
voulaient on a fait un pêché d'orgueil
on s'est basé sur l'angle l'angleterre
où il avait on va dire commencer à voir
une accélération on va dire de la
dégradation de la situation à peu près à
45% de varier anglais je parle ce
contrôle royalement confrères et c'est
vrai qu'en france jusqu'à pratiquement
60%
la france a peu bougé les chiffres n'ont
pas été on va dire mauvais et donc
probablement le gouvernement s'est dit
on attend on va attendre et maintenant
on est dans une situation des patients
jeunes à des camps de fond qui sont
contaminants et qui arrive directement
quasiment l'animation parce que les samu
l'airé que faire dans un état qui n'est
pas bon et donc on a plus si vous voulez
en plus ce voleur de sécurité que
représentaient les sept huit jours en
hospitalisation avant que certains
d'entre eux parcours sans tâche
basculant rien donc on s'est retrouvé
littéralement devant un mur où on a une
arrivée massive et je dirais on est en
train de payer ce qu'on n'a pas osé
faire on va dire il ya peu près trois
semaines parce que là maintenant on est
dans le dur et aux étudiants fermer les
écoles c'est ça on parle beaucoup en ce
moment de fermer les écoles
oui je pense que si vous voulez là le
taux de reproduction est
particulièrement élevé on va dire dans
la tranche 17 21 ans
et là ça flambe mais le problème si vous
voulez c'est quand vous avez une mesure
de confinement et que vous ne la
respectez pas là ça ne marche pas on
peut dire qu'on a un confinement qui est
relativement valable sur le papier le
problème c'est que l'acceptabilité des
français ou bien les français ne sont
pas
on va dire consignant ne respecte pas il
n'en font qu'à leur tête c'est ça
philippe froguel
et je pense que l'exode ganor le
président macro nous a dit en gros les
médecins sont des empêcheurs de vivre en
rond et ça sert à rien confinement est
donc le fait pas et donc à partir de ce
moment là maintenant on a tous vu ce qui
se passe le week-end personne ne prend
au sérieux le nez au confinement qui a
été mis en place il ya quinze jours et
je crains que quoi qu'il arrive donc on
sera pas mobilisés moi j'ai vécu deux
exemples inverses c'est-à-dire roubaix
au moins de novembre et dunkerque il ya
quinze jours
et bien c'est pas les mesures de
confinement qu'on fait quelque chose
c'est quand la population de roubaix à
huîtres très peur et collectivement ils
ont décidé de faire attention et ça a
duré jusqu'en janvier quand j'ai fait le
test pistage de masse en jambes dit
et personne d'attin c'était incroyable à
dunkerque vous allez voir ça va parce
que dans les gens sont mobilisés ils le
font c'est pas la peur du gendarme qui
d'ailleurs se montre peu c'est pas parce
que monsieur matheron dira blanc ou noir
c'est parce que la société aura décidé
de faire attention hélas hélas pour tous
les cas on se retiennent pascal ont
attendu gérald darmanin dans le sujet de
manière souple eh oui enfin le nombre de
jours je connais qui vont qui vont
partir en week-end et j'en connais
beaucoup donc je ne pense pas que tout
le monde fasse très très très attention
dans le point simplement ce que je veux
dire c'est que le président macron à
jouer à l'apprenti sorcier en faisant
que plus personne n'a eu peur plus
personne n'a voulu se confiner et on
quand on a 10 4 ou 6 semaines où il
avait passé tout à l'heure ça voulait
dire qu'on fait un pas qu'on allait
vivre une vie normale et basse est pas
possible si on fait ça ça va être le
drame et je suis vraiment désolé pour
tous les français c'est que la réalité
plus semble que ce que le président
macron avait prévu philippe roca je
reprends vos de sémantique un l'apprenti
sorcier emmanuel macron tous les cas qui
est en baisse dans les sondages on s'est
tellement de notre débat
ce qu'emmanuel mâcon et seul envers et
contre tout et contre tous
regardez ce sondage les français qui
critiquent sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire selon un récent sondage la
doxa dentsu consulting pour la presse
quotidienne régionale 55% sanctionne la
politique de tests de dépistage 67%
dénonce la politique vaccinale 76%
déploré une mauvaise communication
notamment en ce qui concerne le vaccin
astrazeneca messieurs pour terminer j'ai
pas le pas de langue de bois s'il vous
plaît j'ai cette question politique même
si vous n'êtes pas des politiques parce
qu'il s'est écoulé un an depuis le début
de cette crise on a pointé
les problèmes liés à l'hôpital quand il
y avait eu ce qui s'était passé à
mulhouse où un hôpital militaire qui
s'écrit rapidement on a dit on va créer
des lits supplémentaires
et quand on entend par exemple le
professeur timsit dire si jamais demain
vous avez deux malades qui viennent en
réanimation qu'est ce que vous faites je
vais pousser les murs il dit je vais
mettre un lit dans le couloir peut-être
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas créé délit
donc cette question politique est ce que
le système de
politique de l'hôpital est ce que c'est
le vrai problème plutôt que mettre de
l'argent dans le confinement les mesures
de freinage qui coûte très cher à
l'économie qu'il fallait pas très délit
à l'hôpital n'est pas être en flux
tendus comme souvent le sytème hôpital
hospitalier elle est très rapidement
messieurs tous les deux répondre à cette
question compliquée et politique sur
produits l'hôpital de mulhouse l'hôpital
militaire
je peux vous garantir que quand il s'est
monté le médecin parfums les médecins
militaires qui sont arrivés sont allés
voir le pharmacien de l'hôpital du
milieu en disant on est là mais on a
zéro matériel 0 médicament pouvait nous
en fournir et qu'il les a regardés en
dix ans mais moi j'ai rien je suis déjà
en pénurie complet donc il ya un effet
d'annonce il ya zéro efficacité
on avait un an pour essayer de former du
personnel parce que la richesse d'une
nation c'est le personnel sait les
soignants on avait un an pour former
on va dire à vitesse rapide des
infirmiers des aides soignants le
médecin je dirais on est coincé il s'est
tellement lomé pour former des gens pour
s'occuper des patients rien on n'a
strictement rien fait philippe froguel
rapidement répondre également à cette
question en un an donc on n'a rien fait
l'attentisme il est toujours présent on
attend toujours une prise de parole dans
des manuels macron la réanimation pour
des gens de 40 ou 50 ans est
inacceptable et on devrait pas avoir ces
gens surtout dans les pays où il ya plus
jeune le plus de morts comme en
angleterre et on est aujourd'hui la
question elle pas de compter les
réanimations skiff rendait ce qui est
dramatique pour pour les personnes qui y
sont et après quand ils en sortent
ça aurait été d'avoir une vraie
politique vaccinale avoir des vaccins
comme en angleterre comme aux etats-unis
comme en israël de les distribuer
correctement comme dans d'autres pays
voire de l'écho dans le commander
d'autres comme fait la cam a fait
l'autriche aujourd'hui et puis faire des
mesures de confinement qui ont un visage
lui de commander
du spoutnik v1 et ne l'a dit notamment
par exemple en tout cas il est confiné
voilà ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
pour le restants on va pas over et
valdes et réanimation et on n'a pas le
personnel ni matériel ni rien pour faire
ça c'est des paroles verbales ça comme
on dit merci en tous les cas messieurs 1
pierre jeantet reniant et philippe
froguel d'avoir répondu à nos questions
à merci d'avoir été franc et direct dans
vos réponses pas de langue de bois ce
soir sur arte france